foreign
[Music]
Let's Get It Started With as an official
intro as you're ever gonna get this is
the pill pod featuring me as well as
Eric Tate I hope not alleged to be a sex
trafficker Tate thanks Victor brazoni
and today to break down the myths of
well I'm not sure which myth we're gonna
get to but mythologizing
the myth himself Diego rosarin oh my God
does that mean I'm an empty signifier
[__] off bills that was that was that
was that was uncalled for uh violence
no no you're the fullest signifier here
don't worry not to spoil the ending but
if we take BART seriously there's there
is no leftist media possible in a
Bourgeois Society so we are all myths
insofar as we're entertaining at all or
is or is he saying the left is a myth
we'll we'll get to it yeah we'll get to
it before we do I want to do some family
family history since Victor just signed
into the call you guys are both from
South America and both have Italian
surnames how did this happen because
Mussolini was running away from
persecution so he has to slightly alter
his last name and I became what did it
used to be rosalini or no or in Italian
where you add the I to the end you make
it plural oh okay so the I is for plural
so is like Gonzalez Gonzalo rosarin
rosarini right right okay okay got it so
what your family came in the 30s my
family came slightly before no two is it
doesn't match with uh with the second
world war even the rise of fascism
before that my my family came to Brazil
around the early 1900s my my grandfather
was the first one to be born in Brazil
and he was born in 1905.
why
why uh they were looking for
opportunities in agriculture oh Farmers
oh yeah Farmers what about you Victor
yeah my my great grandfather would have
been on my dad's side would have been
born in Italy
um
and then my grandfather was yeah also
similarly I think the first one born in
Chile I could be wrong but I think
that's right and then
I think that he my great-grandfather met
another Chilean woman who was also of
Italian descent Rocco whose last name
was Rocco and uh
and then but that's the only like it's
just one quarter of my family that's
actually Italian just happens to be my
dad's dad's side because like the other
side of my dad's family is German uh and
then like and then the other side and
then my mom is like Spanish and French
and other stuff and and Indigenous
German and Italian are actually the two
most common uh ascendances in in Latin
America my family is true Italian yeah I
just did that genetic oh really yeah and
I'm 94 Italian which is really oh wow
very Italian yeah no I think I I did my
genetics too and I think I'm only like
I'm only like seven percent Italian but
also like 20 something percent like
broadly Southern Europeans so some of
that is probably Italian too they just
like couldn't really match it up but
yeah they came uh so they would have
come I think in the in the early 20th
century or he would have come and I
think they were just looking for
opportunities they were actually all
professionals I remember my dad always
talked about how his grandparents there
was like seven or nine brazoni
grandparents and they were all like
professionals like pharmacists doctors
my grandfather was a doctor so I think I
think I think pills asked us this
because he wants to right now
impossibilitate us from using the
fallacy of authority to speak about the
mythical fascism yes well we're skipping
ahead we'll see the death of the author
but
um exactly that's a sneaky plan I do I
will say that on the German side of my
dad's family then none of them came like
they all arrived before World War II but
like some of my dad's uncles who were
German were like in the Hitler Youth in
in like uh in Chile in like South
America like they were they were into it
they were like supporters and I remember
going to uh visit one of these great
uncles in Miami because he moved to
Miami and I remember finding it funny
it's like of all the places they like to
be like a Jew hater like going to Miami
I don't know it's like it's just like oh
my God
and I remember my dad my dad once like
told him because my dad really liked the
Golden Girls that sitcom and he like
asked him he was like maybe you might
need to cut this out he was just like he
was like The Golden Girls takes place in
Miami it's great right and my great
uncle is just like they're all Jews oh
my gosh
racism that's yeah just so unnecessary
my dad was like what okay yeah but of
all the reasons today of all the reasons
to hate The Golden Girls that's the one
you pick that's what you're doing I know
yeah yeah I mean one of the myths that
we can talk about and and this is this
is interesting because it contrasts the
idea of the myth from barths with Zizek
is the myth of the Jew
oh yeah that would be interesting to
talk about actually because I am I did
find myself throughout the whole time
we've been reading Boris and this
mythology stuff I've I just couldn't
stop thinking about like okay how is
this different from
jajek's ideology or like so so if we can
get there I'd be I would be interested
well I didn't start it and then I assume
Diego will will take over because that's
what why we have him here
um we are talking about myth as has been
mentioned uh we did two episodes already
we needed the automobile myth Diego last
last week yeah thanks for asking me
[__]
[Laughter]
we just watched we watched car
commercials we thought that was beneath
you oh God you guys you got this review
We're Gonna Get You myths on the left
myths on the right myth is
de-politicized speech yet paradoxically
all of our politics is mythical yeah so
if we review quickly
we're reading Roland Bach mythologies
from 1957. myth has a type of speech and
it's not something ancient that's one of
his main points is that dead myths are
not myths
myth is always contemporaneous and uh I
guess this is notable because our age is
no less mythological than the old Savage
times
and I'd like to say more and more people
are are saying this you know they agree
with it
yeah yeah if he's right media runs on
myth politics at least fake politics
runs on myth advertising runs on myth
and myth not just like something false
but myth as a meaning structure or the
meaning structure that makes it hard to
uh tell what's going on so we're doing
some
semiology
semiotic yeah and and there's it's
significant that it's a type of speech
too because
um in in semiology is so sort of
conceived of it right long language long
and speech are almost like separated
from one another right so the the
semiologist is interested in Long which
is the uh sign signifier distinction
right so the the sign is a two-sided
psychological entity the acoustic
impression is the signifier and that is
associated the association is important
with also with a signified which is the
concept or the mental impression
so speeches speech as you know like a
word that is actually spoken would be
decomposed or or formalized let's say in
the schema of signifier signified
whereas speech
um if myth is a type of speech then
there's already like a fullness of
meaning there when we use words in
everyday speech we're tapping on these
meanings that you can sort of study
semiologically but then myth has to add
this extra layer to give it its own kind
of second level semiological analysis
right so these
spoken it can be spoken word verbal
pictorial it doesn't really have to be
speech but the point is that it's parole
it's speech it's posit it's a positive
entity that we would encounter in a
commercial or in everyday conversations
sometimes right yeah in case you didn't
pick up Eric's writing a dissertation on
semiology
in this book what what becomes signs he
talks about soap commercials he talks
about car commercials he talks about
wrestling fashion campaigns and all of
this is uh I think we should get a
counter going for how many times we say
the word bourgeoisie today because the
Mythic structure in which he lived and
we still live is a Bourgeois Mythic
structure and this this is kind of a
whole new wave of of
semiologists in the in the mid-century
trying to privilege speech a little more
in in linguistic analysis right so
that's why you know Linguistics will
deal with speech as language
whereas meta-linguistics will deal with
speeches mythology or as myth or as as
meta language so for this meta language
which myth is also a meta language you
need meta-linguistics a second order
critique of
met meta language yeah of what myth does
which is naturalize history that's
that's the function of myth it makes it
makes the contingent and the historical
appear to be natural and eternal that
that for me that last sentence for me
Eric is is probably the most interesting
one out of the out of the full reading
because it connects back to a lot of
things that will help us understand why
he calls the left and the right also a
myth and um I think that statement what
what Eric said which is very important
to me but I want to get there first can
I make like a recap and because I read
it in Spanish finally and I want to I
want I just want to make sure I'm using
the same language as you guys because
for example you said acoustic image
is for the relationship between
signifier and signify they produce an
acoustic language and the acoustic image
is the sign right uh the the acoustic
image is the signifier as as the form
it's the form of the impression of the
of the yes of the phonetic
part right because inside in Spanish is
weird in Spanish is
like is verbal image which is I think
it's it's very similar I just wanted to
make sure we're referring to the same
thing right so in espanol it will be el
significante el significado which is
interesting because when you use it in
speech it makes it so easy for us to
understand the position of those two uh
let's say elements in in this horse so
there's a thing that is being signified
and there is something that is doing the
action of signifying so it's the
signifier right yeah so the sick so the
signifier is referring to that which is
being signified in in this course but
then one one thing that is important
here and I I always come back and always
and they're coming back to this text is
uh be
um about truth and uh lies in an extra
moral sense from Niche and uh he talks
about this process that we normally do
in language that is a double metaphor
right so so we have this
phenomenological experience of the world
which produces
um metaphorical experience of the world
which then becomes in a way imaginary
and then that that imaginary is
transformed to the symbolical order and
in this in this transition not from not
from The Real World to the imaginary but
from the imaginary to the symbolic is
when we are talking about the
relationship between signified and
signifiers because the signifier is not
necessarily making reference to the real
world it's making taking reference to
the concept of the real world right so
that that is already one degree of
metaphorization that we're not talking
about the thing in itself we're we are
referring to that abstract shared notion
of the thinking itself which will be the
common place in Aristotelian rhetoric
and then that's something that we're
referring to is being signified by this
signifier but the problem is that what
he's saying is that as as language
normally evolves decomposes and finds
new relationships this sign that is the
result of the relationship between the
signified and the signifier this sign
now becomes only a signifier that then
is being used as no it becomes a
signified that is being used as a for a
different signifier to create a new myth
so that's the second level of the of the
relationship am I right yeah you got
levels of reality if you want to call it
that and real reality doesn't appear in
the system even with Mercer like the
signified the signified you call it
concept I think you could call it like a
mental image would would make sense the
thing that you're referring to and then
myth raids regular speech regular
language which is our day-to-day
negotiations that are engaged with
material stuff the myth takes those
words and then repurposes them for what
are usually political Ends by
de-politicizing the actual language yeah
yeah and and Bart does notice you know
this signifier signified structure is
quite popular right so you know Freud
has a version of it too so when you're
talking Linguistics right signifiers the
acoustic image signified is the the
concept right and as Diego pointed out
the signified isn't the thing it's it's
simply the the mental impression the
concepts the associated meaning with the
signifier so you know the signifier can
have many signified signified can have
many signifiers whatever Linguistics
right but in Freud you have the Manifest
meaning say of a dream uh and you have
the latent meaning that would be again
there's a signifier signified pair and
the whole Dream Work would be like the
the third term here I guess would be the
sort of whole but the meaning is the
latent meaning of your dream your
parapraxis your Neurosis whatever
whatever you want to think about and
whatever whatever psychoanalysis is
being interested in there yeah you have
that there's a lot of this sort of
signifier signified structure going on
in theory at this time and still still
is so what the level of the myth the
signifier that creates the mythology is
referring to the signified that was also
a signifier before
so it creates that it creates a chain
dependence in that sense it creates a
meta language because all um all
mythology is based upon this notion that
the original signified it's missing and
it's only implied in the form of the
relationship of the original signifier
that is now taking the place of the
signified in the new mythology
this would be helpful if we could make
diagrams yeah or examples I have these
pictures in front of me examples would
be helpful I was going to say too like
for the listener maybe you should just
play a drinking game and drink every
time you hear signifier yeah there
should already be [__] wasted well
the an easy way to put it would be with
advertising right advertising there are
objects that it's selling there's soap
soap has a purpose it has a it's a sign
in language that you would use like hey
can you pass me the soap I don't know I
don't know when you would say hey can
you pass me the soap but you might but
then the soap and the commercial because
he's not in prison
exactly the soap and the commercial the
way that it's depicted with these
illustrations and animations it becomes
this purging element it seeks out it's
intelligent in a way it seeks out dirt
to destroy it it seeks out bacteria to
eliminate it so this sign or the
mythical sign of soap and you could
apply this to any advertisement we did
cars last week the car is this sign of
freedom and unrestraint which is why
it's always shown in the wilderness it's
shown as a sign of class mobility in
terms of like a luxury car versus a a
family car so each of these has a whole
bunch of it enters the myth Matrix and
has all these associations that aren't
natural to it but they appear As Natural
to it essential universalize in it and
Perpetual there's also a very cool
example with for example margarine you
know like margarine margarine yeah so
margarine is a substitute for butter
and what is interesting here is that the
the the mythology of margarine is using
the sign signifier of the vaccine
because for example in vaccines we know
you get injected with a virus but with a
smaller doses or the virus so your body
will develop a resistance so the virus
itself is not evil is the quantity of
evilness that determines if something is
good or bad and margarine uses the
signifier mythology of the vaccine to
sell itself as a good alternative to
butter
so you see it naturalizes it naturalizes
the logic of the vaccine the body will
develop natural resistance to small
quantities of negativeness and it and it
takes that logic out of context compete
completely naturalize it essentialize it
make it Eternal and non-contingent and
applies to the logic of a margarine
commercial yeah that's funny you know
margarine originally wasn't even uh like
that was a marketing ploy to making an
alternative to butter because margarine
originally was made from like a beef
Tallow
kill you no and it was like it was
originally like a totally different
thing and people like different
different reasons and I think marketers
got their hands on and they're like well
we can try to you know sell a
plant-based one and then and then like
yeah the canola oil version and make it
an alternative but even though actually
I think it's actually worse I don't know
if you can find it we can even put it on
screen but there's four levels of denial
with the relationship of humans
marketing and margarine which is like is
this butter I don't think it's butter
and that I cannot believe it's water oh
my God it's butter and those are all
real
real brands of margarine yeah we have
one called I Can't Believe It's Not
Butter exactly and they all refer to the
to the mythology of not believing that
something is what it is not what is
denying or something like a like a
negative dialectic of affirmation it's
so it's so strange Diego you used to
work in food marketing didn't you in a
former life yeah I used to lie all the
time I used to work in advertising too
but it wasn't lying so much as it was
omitting certain truths yeah you are
here then as a professional myth maker
it was it was very interesting for me to
read this book because I found a lot of
examples like super obvious and it makes
sense that marketing is the language of
Mythology and it's also the language of
bourgeoisie because what what I would
like to take the conversation now is in
the direction of
um I think I think what Roland bartes is
trying to do
is that he's trying to some way push for
a materialistic theory of language
um because what what he implies later on
in the reading is that the the
proletariat the worker which has nature
in hand you know has the tree in front
of him is actually referring to the tree
in hand see he's actually when he talks
about a tree he's referring to the tree
speaks the tree as he exactly but when
when you step away from the tree and you
refer to the tree in an abstract way
then you're talking about about the tree
and on the tree but not not the tree is
not there itself the tree is not being
named it's the absence of the tree
that's being named so in a way the
further you get from Material reality
the closer you are to myth
the closer you are to meta language that
is almost becoming like this autonomous
being non-materialistic and it also
makes a lot of sense that his criticism
is that mythology is essentialized and
non-contingent
and what we should be aiming for in
demystifying mythology is to find the
material roots in the functioning of
language
that's why when we get to politics I
will get back to this point but that's
why I I love his his analysis of the
mythology of the left and the mythology
of the right oh that's a really good way
in yeah can I can I can I come in with
like an annoying question just like
like I just I just feel like I find
myself
yeah just like reading through this
um and feeling like like why is the word
that we're using myth I guess like I
know I kind of asked in a previous
episode how is this different from a
kind of althazarian ideology or like a
kind of lacanian account of like the
imaginary and the symbolic it's just
like I don't know it just annoys me I
think when when like certain kinds of
academic writers or theorists kind of
use a term that seems to have
um one meaning and then kind of like
reimagines it to to apply to just so
many things almost everything I got
Victor perfect question well I think
it's the relationship there's a question
of contemporaneity too because we don't
use the word myth like this really yeah
he was contemporaneous with Alcazar and
Lacon so I guess the term ideology or
the imaginary kind of one is taken
they seem better to me well you have to
understand because they're
contemporaneous they're not necessarily
reading each other at this time so
they're different Traditions that are
interacting like altuzer is a Neil
Marxist and Lacon a psychoanalyst so it
all goes back to so sir eventually and
they're not exactly talking about
precisely the same things but Bart as a
linguist
is talking about myth in the same sense
as it would have been used to
deconstruct an ancient myth so you have
Linguistics you have psychoanalysis and
you have neo-marxism that are all
drawing on these resources in
structuralism in from so sir and then
they come up with different terms with a
bunch of overlap but their disciplinary
or their disciplinarily different from
each other
does myth in French mean something
different though I guess that was going
to be my question it's like maybe that's
the issue right because like I feel like
myth mythology because mythology is just
like precisely not like in kind of the
the common sense English way of using
that term it really would mean the
opposite of something that is used to
conceal like the fact that something's
not real right it's actually like you're
trying you're trying to essentialize
language and the relationship between
the signifier and the signified is
arbitrary
I don't think I'm essentializing I'm
actually just saying that like I'm kind
of stating
a common sense like that it's used in
this way that doesn't mean that that's
the essential meaning is also something
that he refers to when talking about the
myth of the right but I think that
that's but I think that that's totally
consistent with like a with a vicinity
and view of language which is
non-essentializing right that meaning is
use right and like words are used in
this way you can make that observation
the common sense would be the idiot like
the common sense status quo would be a
kind of ideological State of Affairs
right so it doesn't really matter what
people
think is the truth
behind the things that myth or language
is telling them in a way but I mean
this language you just said myth or
language is that just are they just the
same thing well language no as I
explained earlier right like when we we
should reserve the word language for
long and that's what linguists like so
sir are interested in they're interested
in Long right language not speech speech
is something that language has to be has
to be abstracted from right and then
language it turns out is is a two-sided
affair right right has the signifier
signified but we we don't work that way
in every day right the the example from
last week I I bring you a bouquet of
roses to signify my passion for you you
have a sign in front of you you don't
have a signifier with us like those are
formal terms right you have a sign in
front of you I and I'm using this this
sign is signifying my passion the sign
is the bond between the signifier
signified it's the positive entity that
you would actually encounter in any real
situation you don't encounter signifiers
signifiers come out of our Theory our
formal analysis right that's how we get
a handle on the language system but when
we want to look at the second order
system right we can go in two ways right
we can look at ideological critique we
can look at the ways that that that
ideology works with common sense in
order to close language off right to to
Center and close language right so the
we'll talk about this sort of Bourgeois
ideology and and how myth functions in
in a political sense
but then on the other side you have meta
language which is not it kind of works
against
ideology in a way and that it is
transgressive it takes something as Bart
does you take something you take a
commercial and you and you read it
against itself you try to look at the
Historical meaning this is the
materialist part by the way historical
material is a meteorology critique right
you try to look at what is the meaning
that has been emptied out of this right
so using a black soldier to signify
French imperialism well what is the
history that's being flattened out here
what is the involvement of of of black
people in French colonialism being
recruited to the Army even this specific
person who I'm seeing in this ad who is
it what is their past like all whatever
all these questions they're kind of held
in abeyance right they're held at a
distance by the by the Mythic signifier
right it doesn't care about those things
what it cares about is finding a concept
right appropriating a concept to that
signifier which is an orange imperialism
letting you know that that French
imperialism is a kind of natural thing
and look how good it is right it like
anybody can kind of get on board with it
I mean I get all that I I get all like I
get what it's pointing to I just I'm
trying to figure out like what what the
work of calling it myth is doing right
because you know he says I was looking
at it you know he describes how it
abolishes complexity of human acts it
gives Simplicity of Essences it does
away with all dialectics it goes back to
what is immediate and visible like I
guess because to me when I think of myth
I think about I don't know like Greek
mythology or something like that right
it's like these stories that are full of
contradictions that are just like
stories that we know aren't true so it's
just like why use the word myth to
describe what to me sounds a lot more
like ideology or I don't know I mean
maybe that's an interesting point but to
me like as someone who's trying to learn
this stuff I'm like what is the what is
the word myth doing to to give some
analytical Clarity to make me learn
something or think about the world in a
new way and I'm not seeing it yet well
in a way the word myth is is the ancient
Greek word for speech okay it's a
Mythos and logos right Mythos and logos
right Mythos means by mouth right it
means spoken it means speech speed right
means right that's like literally where
we get our word mouth from okay well
that answers my question I mean I was
just looking whereas whereas it's
opposed to words like logos right as in
say logocentrism as deridai uses it or
logos just to mean logic or or reasoning
right it's it's opposed to that it it's
just a it's a signifier he's chosen to
uh and in the same way that the Greeks
had their myths their culturally
unifying they reappropriate signs from
language they turn it into something
else everything is a sign like you see a
you see a bird
um flying with a snake in its Talons
this is a sign that we can now go attack
Troy on the on the following day because
the gods are blessing us so in the same
way they didn't call their myths myths
they called them songs well I almost I
almost thought you were gonna show the
uh you were talking about the Mexican
thing the bird with the snake in its
mouth or something right on the cactus
or something like that yeah that's a
cool myth yeah
yeah I know when when Agamemnon like has
to sacrifice his daughter or something
there's uh there's there's a sign like
that what is interesting about this is
that what this discussion that we had is
the mythologist's job
in the sense that the metal the
mythology's job is to bring historical
and material contingency to the
relationship between how a sign becomes
a myth and unnaturalize the relationship
between a sign and the mythology that is
created with the relationship between
the sign and the new signifier that uses
only the sign as a relationship or form
to unravel that naturalization of myth
is to do dermatologist's work is to is
to prove that the relationship is
historical contingent material social
and dependent on historical political
relationships of of human human
endeavors that's the job of the
mythology according to me which also
kills the myth
exactly but that's if you if you are
because he's a leftist and
railing on the bourgeoisie this whole
book but yeah the point of killing the
myth is to take away its naturalized
power to convince and to sway and to you
know use soap commercials to have you
believe in a cosmic war between good and
evil in your products
why because in a way we have to we have
to place
we have to talk about where do we place
language is it part of the
superstructure or is part of the base
material base because if we place
language or lalang closer to the
superstructure then it means on
dialectical materialism that language
itself it's nothing but a manifestation
of social structures and social
relationships which function is to
perpetuate the basis that produces it
so of course myth is going to be a
self-perpetuating meta language because
the role of the superstructure is to
perpetuate the material basis that
produces them and the job of the
mythologist and the critique of ideology
and what Zizek is trying to do to invert
uh Hegel back to LA can back to Hegel is
that what he's trying to do is to find
again what are those material bases
through politics true politics that is
not present in myths that produces the
possibility for method language to
dominate uh discourse yeah I almost
think of myth method as well as almost
um and it doesn't line up perfectly but
it's almost like the decay of the aura
in Benjamin when he talks about you know
the presence of the mountains and or
like tracing the lines on the bow of the
tree that you're kind of lying in front
of on a sleepy day right you're kind of
breathing in the aura of the thing it's
Unique it's it's there in front of you
it's that it's not over a great distance
there's one of them whereas the decay of
the aura in copying and reproductive
Technologies right that that destroys
the aura and it and it makes the thing
infinitely reproducible and doesn't say
something like uh it meets becomes
to hide the fact that it's anti-natural
yeah it's kind of like a re-ora ing like
it it re-establishes the aura in a
certain way in this context of the decay
of the aura because clearly barths is
talking about mass media culture here uh
it's like almost that the way that mass
media almost works against Benjamin's
thesis that like the aura is going to be
gone and it's just gonna be the mass
media for the masses not kind of against
the masses uh this is the way that mass
media Works back against that and pushes
capitalism and and Bourgeois back into
the center again is that it it
mythologizes it it reconstitutes the
aura around these language objects that
are turned into empty forms right and it
does it differently as well because he
says the capital part of the capitalist
myth is replacing quality with quantity
that reproduction over and over again
and then disability so it's it's the
same reproduction but the the the notion
of elevating quantity and more matters
better more than like the quality of
workmanship is something that Benjamin
would have said yeah like fake food
right you think you think in those
commercials oh that looks so good no
it's [__] fake it's meant to have
photos taken of it and be distributed on
media channels it's not real food if you
eat it you may even die because it's
probably that's toothpaste not vanilla
ice cream what you see what you're
seeing is toothpaste that is supposed to
look more delicious the texture is
supposed to look even better than real
vanilla ice cream it's shiny yeah the
fake thing is better than the real thing
it's shinier it's puffier it's slippery
you spray the tomatoes with shellac so
the water beads on it perfectly that
that's why that's that's why meta
language and mythology is so good and
again it goes back to this sense of of
um what the mythologist has to do is to
denaturalize that which the myth intends
to naturalize we need to reproof and
recontextualize the relationship between
signified and signifier as a historical
material contingency and not to
naturalize essential aspect because why
you see Bourgeois capitalist ideology
naturalizes everything it naturalizes
the relationship of people it
naturalizes the accumulation of richness
it naturalizes economical human behavior
it naturalizes the relationship of power
it naturalizes democracy you see it
naturalizes everything so in the sense
that even the myth of democracy and and
if you want to if we can take the step
into talking about the light the the
left and the right Lenin couldn't care
less about the left and the right for
him the opposition was between
capitalism and communism he didn't he
didn't speak about left and right
speaking about left and right is already
a subjective posture or a subjective
positioning within Library liberal
ideology so of course both are myths
because both they they start from the
mythology of human individuality of
human self-agency of uh you know like uh
you know Justice natural rights you know
all these naturalized aspect of reality
that it becomes myth it can only produce
myth because his meta is meta
referencing itself because so whatever
you produce it cannot aspire to
reference the real world because it's
only referencing that which was
naturalized in an anterior myth so do
you want to get into the myth of the
well I could just say it the myth of the
bourgeoisie is that the bourgeoisie does
not exist
that's the purpose all of this the
entire Mythic structure is to
to pretend that this is a world without
classes that's the entire purpose of it
not naturalized differences well well
let's instead of instead of does not
exist let's let's talk about how it is
named because that's sort of the idea
here like when the tree is named by The
Lumberjack right the The Lumberjack is
speaking the tree Lumberjack is dealing
with the trees it's almost it's almost
high togarian in a kind of way of coping
with things but uh but yeah so then the
Bourgeois the name of the Bourgeois it
becomes ex nominated as he says it loses
its name so what the hell does that mean
what the heck does that mean right right
so there is a bit of a historical
story here in in the sense that the
bourgeoisie is uh emerged in a
historical periods and came to power you
know it used the concept of nation to
overthrow the Arab stock or sea and
French Revolution blah blah blah but
then it then it after that phase the
next phase where the Bourgeois were kind
of the dominant it moved into this
situation where its name then started to
fade away its name became just a memory
it didn't want to name itself anymore it
doesn't have a name
like like the tree if you have a name
you're you've already lost you're dead
which is why he says there's no
Bourgeois party represented in a
republic because they're all Bourgeois
parties even even the Communist party we
have nationalist parties he points out
but no Bourgeois parties if you're
participating Bourgeois democracy you
are Bourgeois that's it yeah sure yeah
there's and there are National parties
though and that that lingers on because
the the idea of the nation-state was
kind of the way that the Bourgeois like
that that was the ideological move right
to tie their fate to the fate of the
nation-state right and and what could
the aristocracy say against that you
have you know divine right of kings you
have we are the cream of the crop kind
of arguments of the aristocracy or
whatever like we have the King on our
side we're better people now that
doesn't work anymore with the
nation-state being the ideological
Center of discourse now being like moved
into the center which is an ideological
move not a meta-linguistic move a
meta-linguistic move or a meta language
kind of move like myth makes would then
take nation and mythologize it make it
natural and that's what happens once
Nation becomes naturalized Bourgeois
disappears because it's no longer needed
it no longer names anything is the point
right yeah so it doesn't exist as pills
kind of said in the beginning there I
just want to uh I want to flesh that out
a bit well it doesn't exist because it's
everywhere that's kind of yeah yeah it's
a it's ubiquitous it's culturally
ubiquitous and it's not really anything
it's it's a fragment of ideology kind of
as he calls it it kind of reminds me of
the way that um no like there's no no
one
um who people will argue are neoliberals
call themselves neoliberals like there's
like in academic circles there's no
position that's actually called
neoliberalism like like there's no
Defenders who will say like oh I'm in
New York like that doesn't exist yeah
true but but then people point to who
the neoliberals are because obviously
they don't want to say that it's a lot
like being neoliberal you don't want to
say it exactly you don't want to say
that you're you're a market
fundamentalist exactly everyone is a
neoliberal yeah you don't need to say it
because everybody is one yeah
everybody's you assume there's a market
fundamentalist there's a market
fundamentalist everybody is until they
prove otherwise because that's just what
I expect I know but I don't want to know
so I don't know this must have pissed
some people off when it was written
because in in 1957 I think the Communist
party was still like the second or third
largest party they had a a quarter of
the vote and he's saying uh you know
they're just they're they're a mask for
the bourgeoisie and it's not to say I
should we should stipulate not every
myth is Bourgeois but all the necessary
ones are so it's a good place to to
start looking like the the myth the left
has myths too and for him at this time
the only one he mentions is uh Stalin
like a a connecting communism with
Stalin as an individual as a as a a cult
of personality that's a a leftist myth
but it doesn't really matter because
it's powerless
but what did he say about the left there
didn't he say Well because most of the
time like uh Revolution can't be a myth
like did I misunderstand that I was just
like what is he talking oh yeah I think
man this was a jarring it was a jarring
sentence to read but yeah Revolution is
the only anti-myth
but you have to be doing it you have to
be you have to be doing it right if
you're not talking about it
almost like the Perpetual Revolution
yeah almost like if you're actually
engaged in a strike then it's not Mythic
but if you're talking about being
engaged in a strike like we do on
Twitter all the [__] day long then
you're doing mythology yeah right is the
difference between the thinking hand and
referring the thing
yeah yeah I I look at it even at Lumen
right it's like the difference between
hetero reference and self-reference
right meta language is language that
talks about language right that's why
it's meta right and whereas language
proper is about things it's about well
it's about signifies concept separated
from the things that they would refer to
if we were but then again then again I
cannot get off this feeling that all
language is kind of meta language if we
take real number so seriously oh yeah
yeah for sure because myth does not
differentiate between different codes
right so you have a written a verbal
like if you ask me how how's your day
today and I got out a sticky note and
wrote my answer on it and showed you you
think I'm really [__] weird but in a
myth right you can switch you can do the
Rebus thing I heart New York you can you
can because myth is retroactive right
myth myth takes already formed meanings
and just crams them into an arena and
then colonize uses them with a concept a
new intention as he says it gives them
an intention that's not sort of from
their history right the Mythic concept
has its own history blah blah blah but
but yeah so myth myth does not
differentiate between let's say
substances right as as shem's love would
call them different signifying
substances like verbal language written
language pictorial language whatever
kind of language you want myth does not
distinguish on that point about
Revolution like when it's happening kind
of being real it's interesting I've been
reading
um mayor Le ponte's adventures in
dialectics so like the very last the
epilogue he kind of talks if he reverses
what he argued in humanism and Terror
and he makes kind of a similar point
where he says like uh
oh yeah revolutions are true as
movements and false as regimes meaning
which when he's talking about the fact
that like revolutions always kind of end
up degenerating into like some stability
that then becomes counter-revolutionary
and it's just like kind of an
unavoidable truth and I think like
there's something to that that like when
the movement's happening that's like the
only time it's actually happening and
then like as soon as you try to turn it
into a regime you turn it into something
that's it's over it's not Revolution
anymore and then that's just stabilize
it well if you take the consequences of
this seriously there's no such thing as
a leftist YouTube channel there's no
such thing as a leftist streamer there's
no such thing as a leftist podcast
because all of that he calls it a mask
it's just masking the bourgeoisie by
putting it on Spotify on YouTube on
Twitch where it's it's it's
serving as entertainment to distract
from the the yeah they're kind of meta
language right they're they're talking
about the left that's the left like us
in a way where the left talking about
the left we're doing meta language here
yeah but but still the way he refers the
the antagonism he places between light
left and right in this book is still
liberal
is still liberal like the subjective
position that he's taking to Define left
and right is liberal he says he's doing
that too yes it's individual he's in
he's kind of individualistic yeah he
says as soon as the left is named you're
just dividing up liberals from each
other exactly exactly because like if we
take historically there's probably three
ways to divide the birth of left and
right is uh young hegelians and old
hegelians which is one one way to take
it very philosophically serious with the
people that set set on the right and the
left after the French Revolution and the
court of Cadiz the birth of liberalism
in Spain those those are the three ways
you can you can trace back the origins
of left and right but if you talk about
Lenin and Stanley and communism it has
nothing to do with left and right then
then the difference between it becomes
idealism and materialism what political
realism what what political materialism
has to fight is
um
political idealism
and political common sense in a way that
I think the right posture for us to take
is the materialistic one is is not is
not to say there is and because when he
refers to the left as as a critique of
the the myth of the left and and you
okay what is the myth of the elect okay
so progress Justice equality like those
are all myths those are all myths
they're layers within layers of meta
language that were naturalized but then
when you take it seriously as a
mythologist and try to deconstruct the
Naturalization of set Concepts and you
say okay so why equality it's a quality
as a universal common trait of of human
behavior but then Mark will say
something like to each according to his
need from each according to her to to
his ability so equality is not is not
really a thing we're striving for no
well maybe in the left but not in
materialist politics you see like I
think I think the job there is to is to
take this reading from when he's talking
about the myth of the left and the myth
of the right he's talking about both
specters of liberalism
they're both they're both ideological in
the way they build their political
speech because again speech is
depoliticizing myth because when you
talk about equality gender identity
affirming a subjective position versus
what you expect of out of Justice those
are all ideological positionings they're
not materialistic they're all
ideological so of course there's there's
that's mythology it's not it's not real
politics yeah he says straight up
there's there's one language that is not
mythical the language of man as producer
so it's exact labor and material and I
should say yeah that's that's
materialism in the sense of historical
materialism as in the sense that the
proper direction is that we make nature
into history by producing things right
but the the false way that myth
mythologizing works is that it turns
history into nature it takes things that
are historical contingent and turns them
into
Eternal and intractable Essentials and
you can you can imagine how if you're
somebody who has has say you're you're
not heterosexual for instance right just
one example among many right these kinds
of myths can be very very stifling for
you all right because they don't accept
they they call you unnatural which is
absolutely absurd right that that
heterosexual
sexuality is is just the natural Eternal
way of things right and I mean who's to
say like you can't argue that on a
factual basis I could say well a very
small percentage of living beings are
actually actually bisexual in this way
but I mean okay but what about humans
okay that's the way we've always been
it's myth right so it becomes very
important to to uh demystify the myth
right as opposed to
sort of accepting it but but when you
are a mythreader you know when when
Barth does give you these three kinds of
reading of myth right you have the myth
maker you have the mythologist and then
you have the mythreader the one who sort
of takes the myth at face value and he
says that this is the person who focuses
on the mythical signifier as on a whole
it's a hole now of meaning and form if
you if you've heard the other week's
episodes I explained meaning and form
are basically the starting point of myth
right and and that's that's Mythic
signification and so I receive an
ambiguous signification Barth says and I
respond to the constituting mechanism of
myth to its own Dynamics I become a
reader of myths end quote so we have to
look at this person who's who's
receiving the myth the viewer the
average myth
imbiber right in order to see how myth
kind of works in its Dynamic
socio-historical movement even though
that movement is a movement of
naturalizing and internalizing and
essentializing we still see that myth
has this trajectory and we can look at
it historically and do an ideological
historical materialist analysis or we
can look at it synchronically as Barth
prefers to do here look at it
synchronically and do a meta-linguistic
critique those are the two options you
have that's why he says mythology is
part ideological critique part sort of
metasemiology
and you can't really get out of it
either right it's like there's the
there's myths that we'd like to have I
think equality Mythic or not pretty
pretty good goal tolerance Mythic or not
pretty good goal but what he says is you
CA these are all produced by the board
by those bourgeoisie and you can borrow
them but you can't produce your own yeah
and that's it or everything yeah every
myth must borrow from the bourgeoisie
myth and the global capitalist
myth almost creates the revolution right
like the board the Bourgeois
yeah yeah it's the only resistance that
they actually ever encounter is the
Revolutionary party right yeah the the
Revolutionary party in in Russia or
wherever right the Revolutionary party
but you know after the revolution fails
and and we all kind of we all we become
the left it's like Revolution becomes
the left the left becomes the myth of
the Revolution right it the left is a is
a signif fire a Mythic signifier here
that naturalizes Revolution but doesn't
do it all it does is talk about it
constantly about how we need it how it's
needed how we can't wait anymore but it
never does anything right
criticism exactly his criticism of the
French Communist party is they sit there
they sit there with their pictures of
Stalin talking about it and debating in
in the whatever Parliament correct but
but for example let let's let's take a
quality for for face value for a second
why do we want equality like if we were
to dismissify the myth of equality
like do we expect do we expect people to
have uh in independent from their effort
ability or capacity or relationship no
matter how strong you are you lift 50
pounds a minute no matter what you could
be an old lady or a or a baby like for
example I can put in the Constitution
like all Brazilians are gorgeous and
smart that wouldn't change a thing you
know like I was born dumb and ugly what
do you want me to do man it's like like
you can involve that idealistic vision
of the world on on me but that that
wouldn't change anything like in the
sense equality is born dialectically out
of the resistance of inequality
that's a good myth I like that one yeah
but but you see equality it's it's
dialectically necessitated from the
Monopoly of the bourgeoisie on meat
why because of the myth of meritocracy
you know the the unspoken
unnatural myth of meritocracy
necessitates for the struggle and
Revolution for equality I like it but is
equality and natural universally desired
good of course not it doesn't make any
sense once you take it out of a
historical context it's completely empty
of of meaning
you know it it is only meaningful and
and as is much is is necessary because
the current material and historical
conditions don't provide it but it's not
like you know like tribes of homeless of
homo erectus were like oh my God we need
to be more equal it's like what what are
you talking about does it make any sense
yeah David wengro and David Graber were
doing it yeah yeah demystifying and of
these sort of myths of history and
equality and Liberty in their book dawn
of everything yeah you can look at it
that way definitely and if you demystify
equality as a as a concept its purpose
was to take down the aristocracy and at
a historical purpose it had a use case
they used it and now it's yeah it's
Bourgeois invented or its purpose was to
assimilate critiques coming from outside
of Europe into the enlightenment
according to dawn of everything the
indigenous critique of the Europeans was
then sort of internalized as the myth of
equality yeah what about the myth of
democracy
we can speak about Greek democracy they
were not very Democratic and what about
French like you need to have a certain
amount of money to vote and then women
are not allowed you know and and still
today there's like a lot of valid
impediments for people to actually vote
so what about the myth of democracy you
know like all these universities the
first place
all these Universal values themselves
themselves as Essentials they're just
like a bunch of [__] that were
naturalized I mean they don't even care
if you vote now because they get to pick
the candidates beforehand you know
exactly I'm sounding conspiratorial but
you know the they but it's true
Bourgeois the Bourgeois they get to pick
the candidates in advance
let's see when you say when you say that
in a cynical way you're like doing uh
barth's number one reading almost like
you're looking at it as an empty
signifier you're see you're observing
how the concept fills the form you're
reading it like a like a skeptic or as
he says the journalist who starts with a
concept and seeks the form for it so you
say I I want to convey French
imperialism or I want to convey how
great democracy is how what signifier
should I use and it doesn't really
matter I can get like a Rainbow
Coalition of of races and make them
stand behind me like politicians are
always doing when they're speaking Yeah
Yeah I could wear some kind of like yeah
I could wear something I could do like
whatever the signifier doesn't really
matter because because it's the it's
empty it's empty you just put a form in
it it just like you know French
imperialism
so what why why is the right more
successful in doing myths than the left
oh yeah
thank you for that Transit he says this
statistically myth is on the right there
it is essential well-fed Sleek expansive
garrulous it invents itself ceaselessly
the the rights the natural state of
things in a way the right has an
advantage because myths become more
stable the more layered they are
because it takes longer for you to get
from the level of the discourse to
closer to the real object of reference
and in that sense mythology
in the right it's building upon itself
in an accelerated way and the left it's
almost unintentionally trying to because
you see to be a conservative is to
conserve is to preserve the state of
things so you want to naturalize reality
and on an ontology as much as possible a
conservative wants stability stability
of ontology stability of language
stability of how we explain the world to
each other and and the results of the
relationships that we have to each other
so a conservative is building myths and
the myths become stronger by repetition
and the fact that they become more and
more natural and essentialized and the
left ones change
so in order to change you need to
produce different myths or to change or
to deconstruct the existing myths so in
that way it's almost like the the right
is adding more layers upon existing
mythology and the left is trying to
delay your existing mythology while at
the same time to build a new mythology
equality is natural progress is natural
you know Justice is natural they're just
trying to build a different myth where
the writers say no Injustice is natural
inequality is natural meritocracy is
natural those are the natural things and
since we already have many many years in
Advantage we already have those myths in
place because we have plenty of stories
to repeat those myths the individual
hero the hero with a thousand faces Hero
Journey we already have those missing
place for centuries and and the left in
a way is trying at the same time to
deconstruct existing myths and
potentially build new ones because
they're they're ideological as well
they're not materialistic and the right
is just building layer upon layer on
existing myth because they want to
conserve the currently existing
ontological view of reality mm-hmm
yeah
yeah yeah because well because that that
wanting to conserve it just seems I mean
I don't wanna it seems like it just kind
of follows all right because the left is
the myth of the oppressed the oppressed
make the world the oppressor who who
Who's oppressing the oppressed is the
one who's in power so naturally they
want to conserve the status quo they
won't want things to change it almost
seems like uh it almost seems like a
no-brainer the way it it falls that way
if you're concerned for the state of
things and you want to see stuff that go
better you know you hop on the
Revolutionary left side if you're if
you're somebody who would prefer to
align yourself with abusers and
oppressors and and but you obviously
don't see them that way you see them as
powerful individual people who are
asserting themselves and and succeeding
and you want to align yourself with
those kind of people then you become
conservative because they need a stable
arena with many many people who are
dispossessed test in order to you know
bring their plans to fruition hire
people make stuff get rich right so you
want to conserve the status quo because
change is dangerous to that situation
makes sense to me but then myth on the
right becomes the myth of the oppressor
in a certain way his language as Bar
says is plenary it is intransitive
meaning it doesn't it's I don't know
what the hell plenary means it's just
everywhere intransitive means it doesn't
take objects right so it's not an object
language it's just a language of
language it's gestural it's theatrical
it is myth it is seductive it's
eternalizing this situation of you know
working class and the owners of the
means of production for example if we if
we still have that structure in our
society which I think we do then
obviously somebody who's benefiting from
it wants to
you know align with it and but the the
sad truth is that many people who
support the right are not seeing any of
the benefits of this activity yet for
psychological or social reasons they are
aligning themselves with that because
they have some I don't know some kind of
attitude towards the world that makes
that more congenial to them I don't know
and I think it's because doing
historical analysis or material taking a
materialist approach to history it
becomes very hard it's time consuming
it's nerd [__] whereas if you are just
trying to conserve the status quo all
you have to do is point at a group of
people and go those people are out of
control they are going to take your jobs
they're going to make your kids gay and
it's very easy right now immigration is
making houses expensive in Canada it's
immigration Doug Ford says as he says
every [__] time it's very easy you
just have to reduce the world into good
and evil and then point out the evil
that's very a very seductive strategy
has nothing to do that is green help
belt opening plan is [__] it's because
of the immigrants of course
I have a conceptual clarification
question so I'm noticing when he's
talking about myth on the left
at uh near the bottom of 146. he talks
about how therefore the one language
that which is not mythical right so he's
talking about one language but like and
then he says this is why revolutionary
language proper cannot be mythical right
so it's so he's talking about how like
you can have a language and I think the
way he justifies it is like wherever man
speaks in order to transform reality and
no longer to preserve it as an image
right so somehow that's not mythical now
earlier I thought we were we said that
it's only like actually doing Revolution
like the ACT that's not myth but like
talking about it is myth or um but he
seems to be saying it's not but then on
the other hand based on what I just
heard you guys talk about in terms of
the right it's like if your language if
the only if the only criteria for your
language not being mythical is that
you're using it to create something
um that like affects the material world
couldn't you also say that the
conservative by using these myths to
stabilize reality right to not make
people act is that not also a creative
act that's materialist in a way that is
also like not mythical insofar as it's
insofar as you want to preserve what
exists right you want to make sure that
it stays the way it is you're like
creating you're you're you're speaking
you're using a language to make
something real to to preserve something
so which one are you giving agency to
the material world or to this course he
says revolutionary language proper
cannot be mythical so what does that
mean yeah what it means is that that was
the question who to who are you giving
agency in this relationship between uh
change is the is the agency in this
course or the agency is in the material
world well sir I'm wondering I'm
wondering what bars means here by by the
fact that like Revolution language
revolutionary language
there's no such thing as revolutionary
language well then what the hell is he
talking about on page 146 at the bottom
I think he means he doesn't mean
language as in speaking I think he means
language as in doing
like the strike the strike is a form of
speech you mean this Victor he said
there is therefore one language which is
not mythical this is the language of man
man as a producer yeah yeah man as a
producer is a language of doing
yeah so so our wire conservatives not
also doing that by talking about like
how they want to keep [__] the same
again because why because their
discourse is produced by the current
existing material conditions which is
already the dictatorship of the of the
of the bourgeoisie
right okay so yeah they're doing
something they're conserving the
currently existing relationships of
power they're doing it yeah right yeah
like myth can flip into like Revolution
can easily flip into myth right and
that's when it becomes the left when the
left becomes the party of Revolution but
doesn't actually do Revolution right
that's that's when it so like again
anything can become
can become myth but I guess the language
that is not mythical is this sort of
what I kind of characterized as this
heideggerian almost conception of of
language that where you're you're
dealing with things but he's like man as
producer you're dealing with the world
you're dealing with things you're
speaking things rather than speaking
about things in in a meta language sense
right so what's interesting the way that
he says that it's it's interesting the
way he says that like this kind of
non-mythical speech is speech that is
fully
um that is to say initially and finally
political right so it's like and not
like myth speech which is initially
political and finally natural
so like somehow that like so that's
another thing that I was like a little
unsure about it's like like what makes
speech political
it defines political as the whole of
human relations in their real social
structure and in their power of making
the world that's how he defines it right
so he almost defines political as as
making the world how we co-create the
world together with one another and that
so that's a creative process it involves
you know history and making and naming
things right we name new things as they
come into existence and we deal with
those things we speak those things in
our relations with one another it's
almost it's like it's an almost a
non-fetishistic
non-conception it's a non-essentialistic
approach to language what he's saying is
that the meaning itself is contingent
there's no such thing as essential
meaning
yeah when meaning becomes essentialized
it's a myth but then but then how do you
know when speech is actually becoming
fully political right so like well
because because it's deconstructing the
mythology within it it's contextualizing
the creation of meaning within
contingency
okay
Victor he's also quite skeptical about
like how successful this can be at the
end he's like the fact we cannot manage
to achieve more than an unstable grasp
of reality doubtless gives the measure
of our present alienation we constantly
drift between object and as
demystification powerless to render it
hold it hold so we're kind of a little
bit stuck in this and I think he's
taking a one step in that direction but
he's by no means like assured of the
success at the end of this path okay so
maybe so maybe he's talking about so
he's kind of saying okay if there is
non-mythical speech it would be this but
then later he's like I'm not even sure
if that's possible kind of thing yeah
that's that's where I was seeing him
almost moving towards you know like the
idea of like simulacrum or something
right right like there's really only the
second order and the first order is
almost like something we I don't know
pause it underneath it right where I
don't know but but this sort of you know
the reason left the left doesn't have
myth is because you know are the Le it's
inessential it's because it we don't
need the myth of Revolution for
Bourgeois Society to function properly
it doesn't need Revolution right it it
does encounter this kind of the through
the Revolutionary party but when it
subdues it it just becomes this sort of
the left thing that is everywhere today
and nowhere really effective right
that's why we're always complaining
about how disorganized and ineffective
the left is at countering these sorts of
things because what we're dealing with
is myth on which is diffuse and
non-localized and really difficult to
even know it when you're seeing it right
and
so I mean the left kind of falls back
into this
you know non-revolutionary meta language
position I guess is what he's saying
here and that's characteristic of I
think the French at this time as as
certain French theorists are breaking
away from the Communist Party they're
seeing the whatever the stalinist
atrocities that were coming out in what
was it the 50s or whatever uh yeah they
were seeing this stuff they were
breaking and they were looking at you
know the left is now a kind of you know
corrupt complicit kind of phenomenon so
it's myth in that to that extent
but we have to get back to the
productive language maybe somehow but I
don't know how and I don't think Barth
does either he does say the the poor the
oppressed the colonized they have to
deal with their immediate means their
non-abstract relationship to the world
only so they don't have time they don't
have the time and luxury to be able to
produce myths which is why I left myths
are always weaker because they have no
power behind them he says the speech of
the oppressed can only be poor
monotonous and immediate so if you're
talking about something like uh
I don't know Health Care reform you you
don't have time you can't
mythologize your inability to get health
care but the bourgeoisie can mythologize
Health Care into something like you need
Freedom you need to have the freedom to
be able to choose your own doctor Better
Health Care is Private health care
there's a myth for you
yeah I mean I found that a lot I was
just reading that section again too and
I mean
yeah like to some extent that makes
sense but it's like how many people are
oppressed to the point where they're
literally only like talking about their
like immediate stuff I mean it's just
like and I also think about that what's
the point they can't speak yeah people
like us who are privileged enough we get
to speak but we are just now becoming
the left and and and giving mouth
service to the oppressed
but still just functioning as a mask for
a Bourgeois mythology but if you want to
ask a question like where are these
people who are oppressed well you look
at where your food comes from you can
look at where your phone gets made you
can look you know well I guess the other
half of the world that isn't outside of
our front doors I mean that'd be a good
place to start yeah when you think that
there's like almost a how many how many
millions of people are kind of starving
say don't get enough food every day I
mean yeah that's the most extreme
version of of not being able to like get
well that's kind of what food
malnutrition is 1.4 billion yeah so that
was that was what I was kind of getting
to it's like it's like that's this
planet this definition here is like I
think really applies to like you know
like by this definition would anybody in
Canada really even count as oppressed
I think it's it's when you you align
well yeah I mean yeah but but
Canada is a is a heavily colonized
country with with many people who've
fallen through the cracks of that but
let's yeah think about aligning yourself
right it's like okay we're the left we
chose the wrong side of course we chose
to we chose the oppressed instead of to
the oppressors what's our myth well our
myths are ineffective because the
oppressed don't get to make myths right
we only get to you know get told what
how to look at the world right that's
what the Bourgeois does it's myths kind
of proliferate and and they they dictate
how it is between humans and the world
right they they put these Norms onto the
masses say the oppressed
and the oppressed doesn't have the tools
to combat that so its myth is
impoverished because the left is
literally sort of chosen the
impoverished side and and we the
privileged left have regressed into our
meta language position where all we do
is communicate about communicating about
communicating and sending leftist
messages and that's all we can do
because what what am I going to do am I
going to talk [__] about my employer am
I going to talk about the next strike
that might be coming up soon no because
that'll endanger my job I'm not going to
do that right that would be that would
be a social suicide which is not the
best thing to do right so I I don't know
it's it it's not the most it's not the
most uh
amenable to myth-making when you're
aligning yourself in that way but like I
said earlier when you find yourself the
oppressor then it's much easier because
all you have to do is just hop on some
right wing Network that's probably
lavishly funded and you get myth out
your ass
you get myth up to your tits I think I
think going back to Victor's comment in
the sense that um
I think most people are actually trapped
in mythology
in the sense that what most people talk
about on their everyday life is is
mythology and of course as you said
Victor mythology here sounds very much
like ideology
in the senses is those things you don't
know that you know you know are those
things that are operating on a level
explaining reality to you and you you
believe in them even if you're not fully
conscious that you believe in them like
for example you believe that effort will
bring you better economical results you
believe in it because the myth is there
you and and everything reflects and
builds upon this myth you know the
struggle the grind get up early you know
yeah I can jump in the mirror exactly
kick yourself in the nuts pull yourself
up by your bootstraps you know like all
this [__] to clean your room like
all this all these bullshits build upon
the myth of meritocracy so I think most
people are are operating on the level of
myth and and even on the level of myth
they justify their position in the world
but that's why I think it's fair to make
the same criticism to the left and the
right because in a way both speeches are
mythological in the sense that they're
non-political in the sense that they are
not addressing the real much material
political and power forces that create
those structures to begin with they just
aspirate on the level of myth you know
the right is on the mist of meritocracy
an individual Merit and the left is
operating on the myth of individuality
by identity politics and and Progressive
agendas you know they're both
mythological
when none of them is talking about you
know and who's going to buy a house
before you die ah none of you okay
that's awesome you know keep talking
about aliens and 20 genders that's gonna
be great that's going to be that's gonna
do wonders for you yeah yeah no let's
let's keep talking about the the left
and the right and you know all these
myths where in the end we're all you
know you don't have land you don't you
don't have a tree to refer to
no one can buy a house yeah fair enough
but let me push back against the leftist
myth that there is a real left that if
we were to only speak about those things
then it wouldn't make a difference
either our podcast could dogmatically be
committed every week to only talking
about material conditions and we just
call each other out every week for
moving into abstraction but the point
remains that disgusting historical
materialism has literally the same
effect as discussing Sports they're both
nothing historical materialism is almost
all of the time its own marker or its
own sign in discourse that is what's it
used for I don't know to differentiate
the real left from the champagne
socialist left but we are all bourgeois
subjects where Bourgeois subjects you
don't get the option to pick that no one
gives a [__] that you are in an
anarchist Discord okay if you are in a
Discord you are a Bourgeois subject
which is not to say you're Bourgeois of
course but you're ranting while paying
rent to the bourgeoisie as are we
currently at this moment I am paying
rent to
a dentist from a family of real estate
developers and they don't give a [__]
how many times I say I'm a maoist I'm
still paying them for the privilege of
saying it in here yeah and look look at
like yeah I guess I guess the wokeness
thing is another kind of leftist myth
right it's another maybe version of the
Revolution myth and obviously like when
you look at it in in a certain way it's
fine right yeah equality yeah people
shouldn't be harassed for their sexual
orientation and their choices of how
they express themselves [__]
obviously with all of that stuff but it
becomes like it it becomes you know
these these things we deliver say new
genders right we that that's kind of a
creative act right and that's and that
is precisely the material that myth
works on right because when a meaning
arrives fully formed that's where myth
can take off and so you get the
anti-woke and you get this sort of
reinvigoration of the right the myth
Factory on the right becomes again it
explodes into action in order to
mythologize the woke movement and turn
it into some kind of well I like it I
like what he says myth operates the
inversion of anti-physis into
pseudophysics exactly it takes what is
not nature and turns it into nature uh
pseudo nature here
pseudophysics
again you have the unnatural natural
distinction there it's not a huge leap
to think of well if heterosexual is
being being that is natural then being
all these other things that woke people
are pushing is unnatural and we should
combat it right so like you can see how
any kind of revolutionary movement is
just kind of coal in the in the
right-wing myth-making machine
which so so it's it's a right-wing myth
then right it's not a left-wing myth I
was thinking about it being a left-wing
myth though and it kind of I was
thinking about this earlier when uh
pills I think or maybe it was you Eric
described like how the Bourgeois like
it's myth it's a myth in the sense that
like uh No One Believes it or something
like that and I was thinking about how
like like on the left it's like there's
this kind of push to be like wokeness
doesn't exist it's not a real thing it's
kind of like uh pretend it's a bit of it
nobody nobody yeah exactly it's a bit of
an interplay there because now we what
do we do we we do land acknowledgments
we we add these sort of ritualistic
phrases into our speech we put our
gender pronouns in our Zoom yeah yeah we
we do these sort of things and those
those are kind of little fragments of of
mythological uh it was he calls them
almost intentions here right we take the
intention of the myth and we just find
the signifiers to match it again so we
say Okay I want to be left I want to
signal I'm left so I'm going to do a
land acknowledgment I want a signal I'm
left so I'm I'm gonna switch between
between he and she when I'm using second
person pronouns in my writing right like
it doesn't I totally do that and Signal
it in various ways but then if you come
like so there's an interplay of course
like things can sort of go back into
myth when they're created and then you
can sort of see how it works on the left
going towards the impoverished depressed
side and you can see then how it works
on the right going towards the oppressor
uh strong man style of of being in the
world I guess now now is that seems to
be what characterizes the right
yeah so I think I think like for example
using natural and unnatural are the
wrong categories to address meaning in
the sense that that's why I like
contingent in the sense that natural and
unnatural keep you on the same axis
where you're looking for Essentials in
and in a way what what what should be
done to this mystify language is to look
for the contingent conditions for that
meaning to emerge and have
historical stability you know like
Victor started asking a question about
why myths okay it could be bag of flies
but no but nobody will that nobody will
endorse it you know the the word myth
itself as a myth already has a chain of
signifiers that gives it enough
stability so that when we speak about it
it appeals to these uh common place of
again Aristotelian rhetorics that we can
endorse it and then we can build upon it
but it cannot be completely anything you
know like because it will create it will
be unstable or it will not last that's
why I think
unnatural and natural are the wrong
categories and contingent is the right
way to address the the emergence of
meaning the emergence of meaning is
contingent and how that meaning remains
stable is what makes it interesting
according to me
yeah because I think yeah when you when
you I think naturalization
automatically kind of implies things
that are unnatural whereas things that
are historical or contingent they're
created they're part of the human the
history of the human race right like the
yeah the production process and and how
we create our world together right
that's still a major Motif right like
I'm pretty sure the dawn of everything
just to even go back to it says we make
our world in the beginning right like it
says we created the world and we can
make it differently right that is a
a motif
I found it interesting when he says
because this is if you if you enter the
the political discourse today it looks
like oh it's left versus right like
these are two equal sides and he goes
you know there's there might be leftist
myths like the Stalin myth but it's
completely inconsequential he's not
gonna even go out he goes after the
French Communist party a little bit but
basically says if there's myths on the
left they're incidental there's no
left-wing myths about uh marriage about
the home about the family about law
about morality and this is kind of a
smack in the face because it sounds like
well if we listen to the discourse of
course the left has things to say about
all of those different things but in his
in his idea the left is just borrowing
from the center the the uh Bourgeois
liberal myth and then redeploying a few
of those things selectively but they're
not making anything and again they're
not making anything because you don't
have the luxury and as insofar as
they're aligned with the pressed in the
poor they don't have the luxury of of
myth baking yeah because we do I guess
we do have metal language we should say
metal language and myth aren't exactly
the same thing like second order
language is where myth kind of takes
root
takes hold but it's not everything right
because you have again you have
ideological analysis which is a kind of
second order again uh and you have
mythologic mythology is is is a kind of
critique of this Mythic myth process
this like meta-linguistics is the
critique of metal language ideology is
the critique of of ideological closure
of historical materialism critiques the
ideological closure aspects and yeah
mythology meta-linguistics critiques the
sort of naturalizing function of myth
right but naturalizing goes against what
the left stands for you know you don't
like when you look at a situation and
you say this needs a change then the
last thing you want to do is
essentialize and naturalize what's
happening right so it's almost like what
myth does is just simply incompatible
with the goals I agree but also I I was
just going to say when we were talking
the other week I think a few weeks back
we were talking about this does the left
need myth like do we need mythologizers
and storytellers to mythologize the left
here the answer would be no because
that's not possible because of the
structure of this whole situation
yeah that's just to put on a map
like us we're not outside of this
critique the the critiques he makes of
the French Communist Party are like
directed at us sitting around talking
yeah I totally want to include us in
what he's saying here because it's like
no we're not we're not above this I know
but him too like he's not escaping this
he's a universe professor at the sorbon
or whatever oh yeah he's the most he's
the mo he reads for pleasure right like
his his it's the theory of the text the
pleasure of reading like he's a total
[__] s s theat you could call right
he's an S theat he's obsessed with
aesthetic analysis right which is
whatever there's been critiques of that
later on
and he wants to give like full
Independence to the writer
yeah like the very at the very end he
stands for like this full Independence
of the writer so that he can freely
explore uh the creativity of language
without being accounted for accountable
for and I think what I think the losing
godzari would say about this is that
this is linguistic imperialism bars
method in implies linguistic imperialism
because of what we said earlier right
myth myth homogenizes language myth
takes all the different codes written
oral gestural all the different ways you
can communicate and it just mashes it
into one pool of material that it draws
on right so actually barth's method of
mythological critique actually implies a
kind of Mis linguistic
imperialism which means that everything
is expressible in language that nothing
out nothing is impervious to being ex no
meaning is only myth deforms meaning not
translation not differences between not
code switching that doesn't that for
barthas myth that deforms meaning he's
placed the deformation in the wrong
place according to this linguistic
imperialism critique and he's going to
subject himself to that critique later
when he writes the death of the author
because his mythologist at the end of
this book has this kind of special
position of being able to read
everything and then when he goes into a
theory of textuality that Authority kind
of dissipates which leaves us in a more
depressing situation as the quote
unquote left that's what that's why I
think like in the end when I was reading
like the the myth of the left and the
myth of the right I come back to this
notion that the left is at its weakest
one is moralistic and idealistic and is
that his strongest when it's truly
political and materialistic
like that that for me is that when you
when you speak about uh mythology and
ideology the left is at his weakest when
you when you talk about real real
political you know real politique and
you talk about material conditions and
you know the people and having the
nature in hand then then you're doing
something worthwhile or when you get off
your podcast and go join a picket line
oh yeah I I think picket line today is
is more is more how do you say uh is
more acting out than anything else
live actually for the no it's for the
three food and the free food and strike
pay obviously yeah yeah picket lining is
role-playing it's cosplay yeah
revolutionary cosplay yes well I don't
have an image I don't have an image to
to offer you as what would be called
revolutionary speech except for a picket
line so even the fact that that's so
what you call it uh thin
today it's like
do we change the world by striking
you could change your Healthcare I don't
think that was through in the 50s I
don't think it's true today like I I
don't think I don't think it comes from
striking really well if you can get
health care that you didn't have before
there's a material condition changed
yeah it is but it's not revolutionary in
a way at the acceleration acceleration
is critique will be that it that will
perpetuate the current existing
inequalities for longer it will give you
a sense of placebo of change but it
would not necessarily fundamentally
change the relationships that symmetries
of power the means of production will
still be in the same hand even if you
have Healthcare so let's just podcast
then it's good
yeah
on YouTube yeah I mean the revolution
will come from Burkina Faso and from
like Africa I don't think we'll we'll be
the ones eh I don't really think we'll
be the ones
yeah yeah that's his first thing he
points out that's interesting with um
Pickett picketing because inoculation is
is the first
um sort of uh Dynamic of this
naturalization or this pseudo physicist
pseudophysics of of myth and he says
that um one immunizes the contents of a
collective imagination by means of a
small inoculation of acknowledged evil
one thus produces it against the risk of
a generalized subversion this liberal
treatment would then not have been
Possible only a hundred years ago the
Bourgeois good did not compromise with
anything it was quite stiff so it's like
yeah you small acknowledged evil in the
situation protects against the risk of
subversion which we talk about you know
a general strike right when we talk
about a general strike and our little
particular strikes though or are you
know if you look at what the Press is
saying about when you're out there
striking uh they're saying they're
talking [__] they're calling Strikers
greedy they're saying they're ruining
the economy they're ignore they're
acknowledging the evils of this strike
left and right even though these are
people with families and probably having
trouble paying bills out there just
trying to get higher [__] wages and
and like get their fair share of the
[__] work they do even I'd even
extend that to the writers in Hollywood
right now and the actors too right most
most actors in Hollywood are not Brad
Pitt or Sandra Bullock right they are
just they are gig people hacking it out
from job to job right so obviously they
want better stuff but this is evil right
because it's [__] with the economy
you cannot read an article written in
English about these [__] strikes
without it mentioning the impact on the
economy oh my God Los Angeles's key
industry is is being parallel creators
by these greedy [__] right like oh my
God like so you can inoculate easily
inoculate against these leftist
movements right and then again all we
can do is then fall back into our
leftist myths and just complain about it
and and write a book called mythologies
and write an awesome after that you're
called Myth today you can have free
healthcare while we privatize all the
oil in the land and then you're going to
be very happy about the healthcare but
guys I have to say goodbye my I start my
next recording in 10 minutes and I have
to prepare it's a good place to end
anyway I think yeah I think we've run
out of Steve critique has run out of
steam our critique
an even more radical critique of
critiques exactly since you find the
next one all right well thank you
everyone thanks guys and Diego thanks so
much for coming on I know you have a
gold a gold YouTube uh plate behind you
but do you wanna do you want to point
our our uh listeners anywhere you mean
to my channels no don't go there
[Laughter]
if you can invite me more often I will
be very very happy about it because I
miss your faces I miss these
conversations you guys are super nice
super kind conversation is always super
fun and the readings are interesting so
whenever you want me back I'll be back
it's always a pleasure yeah
oh it's a pleasure all right signing off
later guys later
foreign
[Music]